how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
last night we got our final episode for
season one of marvel's what if it was
definitely one of the better episodes of
this series and it was really great to
see the avengers go up against the
ultron that i wish we actually got in
the mcu in age of ultron now i know some
people were kind of bummed about that
post credit scene even though it is
pretty sentimental and it does set up
season 2 i know a lot of people were
hoping that it would connect to the mcu
live action somehow and i was definitely
one of those people but in this video
i'll explain how i still think that it
does connect directly to the mcu and how
we'll see some of this bleed into
multiverse of madness i'll also talk
about how i actually believe the
illuminati for the main mcu were
introduced in this episode or at least
how they are going to come about in the
mcu was introduced in this episode and
of course i'll talk about that deleted
episode because what if was supposed to
be 10 episodes long but they removed one
and why it was probably confusing for
some people and i know that some people
just have a lot of questions about
what's happening in this episode so
don't worry we'll do a complete
breakdown and then talk about some
theories and which i think we're going
to see in multiverse of madness before
we get started be sure to let me know
what you rate this episode 1 out of 10
in the comments down below and if you
love marvel content be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos so the last episode left off with
the watcher asking strange supreme for
help in defeating ultron to save the
multiverse obviously strange has agreed
and now the watcher is recruiting other
members and we start with captain carter
the scene with captain carter is
basically the first scene from captain
america the winter soldier it's almost
word for word except obviously it's not
steve rogers as captain america it is
peggy carter as captain carter she goes
on to fight bartrock just as steve
rogers would in the winter soldier until
the watcher comes he says she's been
chosen and she is recruited for the
guardians of the multiverse we then cut
to ego taking over the body of peter
quill so he can end up taking over the
complete universe we see the same exact
dairy queen that we saw in the beginning
of guardians of the galaxy vol 2 where
ego and peter quill's mom were ego seed
has begun growing and we can actually
see ravangers trying to fight the seed
eventually t'challa's star-lord shows up
and ends up saving peter quill and it
looks like he might have destroyed
temporarily ego remember that this is
just a body that he creates the actual
living ego is the living planet so this
most likely in this universe at least
only temporarily delayed him just by a
bit this scene is kind of cool because
t'challa's star-lord saves peter quill
who in our universe is star-lord himself
t'challa says that him and the others
will take care of it and peter says that
i got it i'll hang back with the giant
baby man cape dude it's good to know
that even in this universe peter's humor
is still the same but t'challa turns
around and sees the watcher in which he
tells him he's been chosen now the next
scene is where people might have got a
little bit confused we see tony stark in
a sakar hulkbuster type iron man armor
also with him is gamora with thanos's
sword as you probably noticed all of the
other guardians of the multiverse were
pulled from episodes that we have
already seen so this scene right here
may be a bit of an outlier to some
people but there were actually
originally supposed to be 10 episodes of
what if but for whatever reason they've
removed one and they only had nine and
obviously the one that they removed was
this one with tony stark and gamora now
we don't really know what this episode
could have entailed but there have been
some leaks out there that give us a bit
of an idea that kind of seemed to line
up with what we see here what the leak
said that this episode would entail was
in the battle of new york when tony
stark took the nuke through the portal
instead of hitting a ship he actually
directly hit thanos's ship then he
missed the portal back to earth and he
ended up in sakhar the same place that
thor ended up in thor ragnarok where he
became a gladiator the nuke hitting
thanos's ship apparently weakened thanos
enough for gamora to come in and
actually kill him tony would end up
being a gladiator on saqar much like
thor was and gamora would end up going
to zakar to try and kill tony stark this
was to make sure no infinity stones ever
got used but of course obviously she
realized that tony stark wasn't actually
a bad guy the two of them then got
together destroyed the infinity stones
and then went to itree the dwarf who we
saw in avengers infinity war who made
thanos the infinity gauntlet and they
are actually destroying the infinity
gauntlet in this scene that's what the
leaks told us we missed in that episode
not sure how true that is but it seems
like that is probably what happened the
watcher shows up and of course recruits
thanos killer gamora and with her she
brings the device known as the infinity
crusher which can crush and destroy
infinity stones now another interesting
fact about this scene that we saw with
tony stark he is still talking about
putting a suit of armor around the world
it's ironic because in avengers age of
ultron this is ironically what caused
ultron to be created tony stark
following this plan now after we see
tony stark with gamora we go to
killmonger in which the watcher shows up
and he calls them eric stevens tony
stark's former protege and killer and
side note luckily we didn't have to
watch tony stark die again in this
episode killmonger gets chosen and it's
a good thing that he does because pepper
potts shuri and the dora milaje were
coming for him and they break down the
door right after he's chosen kind of
giving us a little bit of a feel of what
would have happened in that universe
eventually it looks like they probably
would have taken down killmonger then we
cut the thor in vegas which he
apparently really really really loves
now on earth he is fighting ultron bots
which is very curious because these bots
exist in his universe which were
completely different than the universe
that ultron took over originally now
thor's pissed off because he was going
to go on a date with jane give her
flowers like he did at the end of his
last episode for party thor and he said
that he was even going to wash his hair
which means that he was really going to
try on this date the watcher tries to
talk to him but he was so pissed off at
the bots that he just keeps on killing
them until the watcher eventually grabs
him and freaks him the heck out he
screams hysterically and it made me
laugh hysterically in a way that i
haven't laughed in a long time watching
the disney blood show now very important
part here thor is holding the head of
one of the ultron bots and as the
watcher brings thor to this kind of void
in space-time thor brings the head with
him we find out that doctor strange kind
of created this little pub it was
created from the memories of peggy
carter which is why we see a picture of
steve rogers on the wall there's a
little node to thor ragnarok here where
thor asks for a beer and steven strange
gives it to him just like he gave him
the beer and thor ragnarok where the
beer never runs out the watcher shows up
and tells them that they have been
chosen for a very particular reason for
their skills he says that not just a
universe is at stake but a multiverse is
at stake and he dubs them the guardians
of the multiverse the watcher then
explains that ultron is now a cosmic
being having omniscience having a
synthetic body being powered by the
infinity stones in which doctor strange
then explains the infinity stones just
like wang did in the beginning of
avengers infinity war the team then goes
over the plan separate the stones from
ultron then destroy them with the
infinity crusher that gamora brought
with him also this whole entire time
killmonger is messing with one of the
heads of the ultron bots this he
obviously uses at the end which we'll
talk about in a bit and the plan begins
we go to a planet that doesn't have
enough intelligent life to attract
ultron then we have a few touching
scenes here peggy carter talks to
strange supreme asking him about the
peggy carter or captain carter in his
universe in which he explains that in
his universe he has a captain america or
had because his universe is gone but in
his universe steve rogers took the serum
not peggy carter and this brings peggy
some joy then the whole team toasts
together to what could be their death
but also toes to the guardians of the
multiverse in which thor then exclaims
the multiverse and shoots blast of
lightning into the sky in which that
definitely attracts ultron thor then
completely ignores the plan that they
took together and attacks ultron
immediately which it does absolutely
nothing and ultron is pretty much
embarrassed for thor at this point him
being a cosmic entity is almost just
annoyed with thor that he would even try
even though thor yelled his battle cry
viva las vegas now before the battle
commenced doctor strange protected all
of the guardians of the multiverse with
a spell the true plan and battle begins
and they begin to fight ultron the fight
is pretty epic we see things like
strange multiplying mjolnir strange
bringing in the what if zombies strange
using some of the demons that he
possessed to fight ultron and eventually
they do take the soul stone from him now
eventually ultron gets tired of the
games that they're playing with the
fight and decides to simply use the
power that he has to destroy the entire
planet and it looks like he also
destroys the entire universe as well as
the guardians of the multiverse are
transported to the universe in which
only black widow is alive black widow is
really skeptical of who the guardians of
the multiverse are considering the fact
that she's the only person alive in her
universe but luckily her and peggy
carter and peggy's universe end up being
best friends so she knows a lot about
natasha including the name of her father
ivan and she even drops the name alexi
who of course is the red guardian whose
shield natasha would end up using later
on in the episode now since ultron is a
cosmic entity he finds them with ease
the avengers attack him and ultron gets
pretty pissed off and says i can destroy
entire galaxies with a thought why won't
you all die he there tries to wipe out
this universe like he just did the
previous one however doctor strange
absorbs his power and essentially
reverses it and i believe that strange
supreme could be the villain of season 2
because he now has ultron or at least a
part of him inside of him just like he
absorbed schumachorth and some other
demons and now has a part of them inside
of him the same goes for ultron he
absorbs some of his power so therefore
ultron must be a part of him now in some
way shape or form now this confuses even
ultron himself that he's able to absorb
his power this helps the avengers kind
of get the upper hand on him until he
has enough again and uses the time stone
to kind of freeze everybody in time
however doctor strange has a time stone
of his own so it kind of looks like they
cancelled each other out because doctor
strange was outside of the effects
strange uses the power of shumagorth and
a few of the other demons that he
absorbed in his famous episode and the
avengers pinned down old tron long
enough to get the infinity crusher on
top of him it absorbs all the stones in
which then explodes however ultron is
not dead and we then see the camera pan
around all of the guardians of the
multiverse much like the very famous
scene in the very first avengers film of
course ultron is not dead and he
explains that the infinity stones are
unique therefore the infinity crusher
could not destroy these stones because
they are from a different universe
ultron then realizes that it is strange
protecting everybody and goes for
strange all hope seems lost until
natasha finds the arrow that has the
zola virus in it with the help of peggy
carter she shoots it right into ultron's
eye infecting him with the zolovirus
zola then defeats ultron in a scene that
is very much like when ultron defeated
jarvis however like i mentioned
killmonger had been tampering with one
of the ultron bots's head he manages to
hack this and then he ends up taking the
vibranium armor from ultron and taking
the infinity stones however zola is
still there and of course he wants the
infinity stones and the armor back and
the two of them battle it out until
eventually strange supremes realizes
that they weren't supposed to win they
were simply supposed to separate the
stones from the body and since the
stones were already separated strange
turns killmonger and zola into stone we
then cut to the watcher and strange and
ultron and killmonger are now in a
pocket dimension inside of a pocket
dimension because strange is in a pocket
dimension as well the watcher asks
steven if he will watch the pocket
dimension and states that if it cracks
and they escape it's going to
essentially be the same thing the
destruction of the multiverse in which
steven agrees that he'll watch and i
definitely think that this is the setup
for season 2 in which strange is
probably going to be the villain he
might see those stones as a way to undo
the damage that he did as in the entire
destruction of the universe in episode
3. he could see the stones as a way to
get his universe back and christine and
as i mentioned before he definitely has
ultron inside of him at least a part of
him now the watcher sends everybody back
to their respective universes at the
exact point in time where they were
taken away much like an avengers in-game
where steve had to return the infinity
stones to the exact point in time when
they were taken he returns everybody but
natasha in her universe she was the only
person left alive literally the only
person so having her in that universe
probably won't make any difference at
all so he puts her in the universe from
episode 3 the one where natasha actually
died when we last left that episode loki
had pretty much taken control over the
world all of the avengers were dead
except for steve rogers and captain
marvel was called so we go to this
universe and loki with his asgardian
army is fighting captain marvel nick
fury steve rogers and now a new black
widow from a different universe in which
black widow quickly makes easy work of
loki fury realizes that this is not the
same black widow but he's okay with it
then we go to the post credit in which
we are back in peggy carter's universe
natasha tells her to kind of brace
herself in which we find the hydra
stomper that steve rogers used in the
very first episode and natasha tells us
that there's somebody inside of it
telling us basically that steve rogers
is still alive this is also setting up
at least one episode for season two and
like i said i know a lot of people were
expecting some type of a tie-in into the
mcu into multiverse of madness and which
we did not get or did we not directly
but if we read in between the lines we
kind of see that some of this is going
to bleed over recently there was a
leaked photo for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness concept art showed
that ultron bots will indeed be in the
film also not to mention the illuminati
is supposed to be introduced in doctor
strange in a multiverse of madness as
well and i believe we could have seen
the start of that here because the
illuminati is essentially the guardians
of the multiverse now in the comics they
simply protect the world and their
universe they consist of the leaders of
different groups iron man from the
avengers mr fantastic from the fantastic
four professor xavier from the x-men
black bolt from the inhumans namor the
submariner of atlantis and of course
doctor strange but we know marvel
doesn't always do a complete adaptation
of the comics in fact more often than
not they don't and the illuminati are
also supposed to guard the infinity
stones in which there aren't really any
infinity stones in our main mcu right
now which leads me to believe that the
illuminati are going to be introduced so
they can protect the multiverse they are
coming in multiverse of madness after
all and why would they come and be
formed if it didn't have to do with the
multiverse so in the mcu instead of the
illuminati being protectors of just one
universe i believe they are going to be
protectors of all of them essentially a
guardians of the multiverse but with a
full-time job of protecting the
multiverse now the final thought on this
episode and the series as a whole is not
to forget what the producers of the show
said they did say that this is canon to
the mcu now with the multiverse that
means a lot of things can be canon to
the mcu but the biggest thing to focus
on here is the watcher if the watcher is
canon to the mcu that means that not
only is he the watcher for these
animated universes but he is actually
the watcher for our live action
universes as well meaning that he could
show up in live action form in
multiverse of madness and if that is
possible that means that it is also
possible for any of these other
characters to show up in multiverse of
madness as well in fact it has been
rumored that peggy carter is going to
show up in the movie that's just a rumor
for now but the basic principle of this
of the multiverse is that literally
anything is possible ultron stated that
in episode 8 and marvel even advertised
that in their promos for this final
episode they said that anything is
possible in the multiverse so i would
definitely expect some remnants of what
if to appear in the mcu at some point in
time most likely in multiverse of
madness now i am genuinely curious to
hear what you all had to think about
what if as a series as a whole so let me
know what you rate the entire series in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all the latest mcu
news for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
[Music]
you